a final farewell
but many of these 23 soldiers don't have
relatives here to mourn them
they're on the other side of the front
line
their comrades stand guard
paying a final tribute
i joined this unit recently it's an
honor for me it's part of my family and
today the man was snatched away from our
military family we are very deeply hurt
we feel emotional
he gave his life for our country may he
rest in peace he will always be
remembered
may god take him to a better place
because it's a holy deed when one
sacrifices himself for his country
he's a martyr
it's the last family they had
priests say their final prayers
and coffins are taken on their final
journey far from the soldiers homes
with no certainty their parents siblings
or partners will ever get to visit their
final resting place
most of these
soldiers of walnut vacca
most of them were brought here from
there
unfortunately some of them were very
young
i'm sorry this is very difficult for me
but very young men have died while
protecting ukraine protecting all of us
the war in the east is fierce
and the russians appear to be slowly but
surely grinding the ukrainians down
but ukrainian forces continue to resist
russian artillery has pounded the second
largest city kharkev and the port city
of maripo
in the freezing graveyard of dinipro far
from killing the will to resist
losses on the battlefield further fuels
the anger
all we can think of is revenge revenge
avenging our men this gives us
motivation to protect our country it's
the only way
the conflict in the east has been going
on since the invasion of crimea in 2014
an estimated 14 000 people have been
killed
these latest casualties are since the
recent russian invasion
this graveyard is full of young men that
have died from this conflict
but the reality is as long as this war
goes on
more will follow
assad bake al jazeera denipro